I want to listen to
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the 68th chapter of
Alam
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
in the fifth verse which we discussed
last night. Alhamdulillah
You shall see and they shall see.
This
goes back to the original statement
upon which this sentence is formed
and upon which it's founded. The
statement of Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
You, oh Muhammad, O messenger, are not
in the least bit insane.
And so he says,
"Hence you shall see soon and they soon
shall see."
And so for this reason and because of
this meaning
some of the scholars of ali
they give different titles to different
when we use a word to
connect two sentences and right or
hence
or hence. forth etc.
This particular is referred to as
Allah says in the sixth verse,
you shall see and they too shall see and
observe in no uncertain circumstances,
in no uncertain terms
which Which of you is the misguided?
Which of you is the methun?
Now notice he didn't say the word meon.
It's almost
this word is not even worth
entertaining beyond what was said
previously.
He doesn't bring it up again. Subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
And so he uses the word instead
in the Arabic language has two main
meanings.
Is to
turn something away to hinder something.
Something is
off.
And that as well is used with sometimes
fat.
And sometimes
fat in the Arabic language means to burn
something.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
Now these two words, these two meanings
to turn something off or to burn
something. Why do they have the same
word that is used to describe both of
them?
Because they both share a similar
meaning. And that is why Allah refers to
crisis as a fitna. Why is it a fitna?
It's almost putting
a piece of metal into an oven to burn
it, to bring out its true composits, to
bring out its true colors. Right? When a
person is enduring a fitna, it's like
he's in a furnace. And how he behaves
under those circumstances is what his
true colors are. And so the fitna is
what brings out a person's what? A
person's true colors. That's why it's
referred to as a fitna. But it's also
referred to as a fitna because it can
easily what? It can easily misguide a
person. A person can easily step off of
the path as a result of this fitna. And
so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
"You shall see soon." and they too shall
see very soon which of you is truly the
misguided one. He goes on to say
he says indeed your Lord
now notice the wording here. He didn't
say
you have to always notice that.
He says indeed your lord. Who's he
speaking to? The prophet Muhammad
sallallah.aii wasallam. That means
something. Indeed your lord.
He is most acquainted and knowing of
those who are misguided from his path.
and he is most acquainted and knowing of
those who are upon guidance.
Your lord
ascribing himself to the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
this is to mean that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
it is not just any lord that is being
described. No, it is Allah as described
by Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam. It is
Allah as obeyed by Muhammad. It is Allah
as guided to by Muhammad sallall.aii
wasallam. So he is his messenger. It is
your lord. He then goes on to say,
so notice the wording here. He says,
"Indeed, your Lord, he is most
acquainted and most knowing of
those who have been misguided from his
path. And he is most acquainted
and knowledgeable of those who are
guided." So do not obey
those who disbelieve.
They are the ones who
disbelieve. Do not obey the
disbelievers.
What's that mean to us? So if I go to a
doctor and he's not Muslim and he says,
"Take this medicine here three times a
day.
Is it the command of Allah that I
disobey him? Because
right do not obey the disbelievers.
The prophet
wasallam
when he left in his migration from Mecca
to Medina
he chose the most trustworthy and
knowledgeable of guides.
to take him.
And , of course, this is a desert. It
is very unforgiving. One slight mistake,
you just miscalculate one well and the
whole part is dead. That that's the
danger of the desert. And that's why the
Arabs referred to the desert as a
[Silence]
one who wins, right? They referred to
the desert as a mafza, the place you go
to win.
Why are they calling it that?
Because they are so afraid of the desert
that they don't even want to speak badly
about it. So they would refer to it as
right
trying to be optimistic with respect to
the desert. It's a very unforgiving
place, a harsh place, a dangerous place.
And so who did he choose to guide him
knowing this verse?
He chose the most knowledgeable and
discreet trustworthy
guide because there was a contract on
him. Whoever
was to you know what they had tried was
whoever successfully murdered the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam would have
such and such
Right? And so whoever kills Muhammad for
him is 100 she camels. You know what
that means? 100 she camels that time.
100 she camels. In this time you would
be a wealthy man. At that time you are
zero to a multi-millionaire
overnight. So that's the incentive. How
many people were looking for him?
Everyone.
And so who did he choose to guide him?
He chose a man that was not Muslim. He
was not. And he never became Muslim
actually, but he was trustworthy and he
was competent.
So we understand
to mean
we understand it to mean do not obey the
disbelievers meaning in with respect to
guidance and misguidance with respect to
good and evil with respect to morality
with respect to right and wrong with
respectful with respect to lawful and
unlawful. This is the position of Allah.
The context is everything, right? The
context tells us what's really meant by
the sentence. So the sentence on its own
don't obey any disbeliever.
But the sentence in its proper context
it comes to light to mean what? Do not
obey the disbelievers in the
disobedience of your Lord. He knows and
he is acquainted and he most knows those
who are guided and those who are
misguided. So do not obey the
disbelievers.
And so
this obedience here is with respect to
two things. Number one, obedience to the
of the disbeliever
with respect to that which is the sole
dominion of Allah and his messengers,
right?
knowledge of the unseen, good and evil,
right and wrong,
true and false,
things about this life and the
hereafter, that is the sole dominion of
Allah
and
in anything that entails
disobeying
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. And that goes
for a Muslim and a non-Muslim.
There is no valid or binding obedience
in the disobedience of Allah.
there is no obedience to to the
creation of Allah in if it entails the
disobedience of Allah. Then we have a
very very interesting verse. He says
this is speaking about the
he just mentioned.
He said they wish
they desire they they they would rather
that you
do what is called
so that they can respond with
Huh?
[Silence]
This is important too.
This is one of the most important
lessons of the of the entire Quran.
As a matter of fact, Albkar
dedicated an entire chapter just to this
topic.
We have two things. We have
[Silence]
We've got two things here.
which is mentioned here.
[Silence]
Did you not understand?
is that a person
sacrifice that a person compromised the
truth
for the sake of another. This is called
mud. And when you hear the word for the
sake of another, this can be a man and
his wife. This can be an employee and
his boss. This can be a man with his
friend. This can be a parent with his
child. Alm very dangerous. And that is
that a person compromises the truth
in order to please another other than
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. This is
called mud.
Here Allah says they wish that you, oh
prophet, would compromise so that they
could compromise
in reciprocity so that they could
reciprocate your compromise.
And there are many examples of this.
One of their offers to the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
was
we will if you are desiring women we
will bring you the finest women in all
of the Arab peninsula. If it is money
you desire we will make you the most
wealthy amongst us. If it is if it is
authority you are after, we will make
you our king and put a crown on your
head.
Anything for you to stop this.
And the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
refused.
In some narrations, it's narrated that
he said, "If the sun were in my right
and the moon were placed in my left, I
would not compromise a thing."
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
wanted the mushri to become Muslim. Why?
To save them from the hellfire. Correct?
Not so he could have a lot of followers.
And so did he have a good cause? Yes,
the best of causes.
And so they came to him and said,
"Listen, how about we make it 50/50?
We'll worship your god for a year." And
that includes the Hajj season, by the
way. Okay? And you'll worship our gods
for a year. We won't curse your god for
a year. You won't curse our gods for a
year. You know, 5050. We could all Hey,
look. There's plenty room
for all of us in the pond, okay? We
could all get along. We could share. We
could even share the Kaa if you want.
Right? This is the compromise.
And the prophet sallall.aii wasallam in
the narrations
considered this. He didn't have anything
from Allah clear
with respect to this. He did not agree
but he was awaiting
he was awaiting
the command of Allah. And so you know it
crossed his mind you know maybe if they
worship Allah for an entire year it will
take you know
you know
and maybe they on their own will slowly
know become Muslim.
And so Allah sent down the verses
[Silence]
Sometimes this is translated
incorrectly.
Somebody
just say it.
[Arabic recitation]
religion.
So to you your religion to me my
religion
right
one love you know one
love
you worship other than Allah I'll
worship other than Allah we'll all get
along just don't interfere
leak.
Could that be the meaning of the verse?
To you, your religion and to me mine?
No
does not mean religion
means what?
No
in the Quran has three meanings.
Religion, judgment, and actions.
Here it is.
It is actions to you, your actions.
You're going to have to pay for those
actions. And to me, mine.
not to you your religion and to me my
religion. No, he does not affirm their
religion.
And so the point here is that they wish
that you would compromise so that they
would compromise. I will end with this.
The question is as follows. Let's say
a person wanted to be a king. He wanted
to be he wanted authority. Okay.
And so
this person comes out and claims to be a
messenger of Allah himself.
And they come to him and they say,
"Look, if you want authority, we will
make you our official king." Okay?
And then he agrees to that.
How long is his kingship going to last?
Can he can he ever come back after that?
if they stop obeying him and he's
no longer the king, can he go back to
calling himself a messenger again?
That's it. It's gone, buddy. You lost
all of that because you compromised.
When you compromise, it means that what
you have is cheap. That's what it means.
And so if our prophet were to compromise
with the Quran, that means it's not
worth it. That means our pleasure is
worth more than his book that he claims
came from Allah.
So
no, not even one hair,
never, not one God, not one,
nothing. This is what I call to. And I
will not compromise not even 1% of that
because as soon as he compromises 1%
that automatically cheapens everything
he is calling to
because if it's worth compromising it's
not worth anything.
Subhanahu
[Silence]
Oh,